thank you outside of Georgia's
Parliament demonstrators stood their
ground against riot police firing tear
gas and water cannon the unrest came
soon after politicians gave their
initial backing to a controversial new
law it would force non-governmental and
media organizations to register as
foreign agents if more than 20 percent
of their funding comes from overseas
critics say the law will suppress press
freedom and Civil Society
and it's highlighted broader discontent
of what is seen as deepening alignment
with Russia by the country's governing
dream party led by prime minister Iraqi
garagushbili steadily the current
government the Georgia dream political
party
has moved the country backward in recent
years toward a more pro-russian
Direction and this law that is being
proposed is almost a copy of one that
Russia has
the European Union's foreign policy
Chief Joseph Burrell has called the law
a very bad development protesters say
the bill is undemocratic and harms
Georgia's chances of joining the block
I came here because I I know that my
country belongs to Europe but my
government doesn't understand it and we
believe that this is a part of the big
play this is a Russia's play and purin
is facing uh damage in Ukraine and they
want to gain something here so we are
here to protect our country because we
don't want to be part of Russia again
dozens of media and Civil Society
organizations affected by the
legislation have said they will not
comply
on an official visit to the United
States the Georgian president expressed
her support for the protesters
no one needed this law it came
but maybe it was dictated from Moscow it
needs to go it needs to be repealed any
way you want I said from the first day
that I would veto this law and I will
veto it
[Applause]
the law highlights deep divisions in the
former Soviet state on Monday a mass
brawl broke out between MPS debating the
bill
with Parliament able to overturn a
presidential veto and the law passing
its first reading comfortably protesters
see no choice but to keep pressuring
politicians from the streets Freddie a
car Al Jazeera